und jetzt das heute schon mal
mit kai soll richter und claus kleber
guten abend interessante zahlen heute
bei der spd sechs zweier teams standen
zur vorwahl um den vorsitz nur einer von
den zwölf leuten es bundesweit prominent
klar als bundesminister und vizekanzler
olaf scholz musste heute abend platz
eins schaffen hat er auch aber jetzt ist
ko runde und scholz mit seiner partnerin
klara geywitz muss den atem der
verfolger im nacken spüren so nahe sind
die nur 1,6 prozentpunkte weg der
ehemals nrw finanzminister norbert
walter borjans und seine crew
teamkollegin saskia esken informatikerin
bundestagsabgeordnete aus schwaben
sie waren außenseiter seinerzeit heute
abend sind sie ganz vorne mit dabei
die partei regie machte es spannend um
kurz nach 6 uhr am frühen abend
schlängeln sich die auszähler von oben
nach unten im willy-brandt-haus leises
gemurmel der schatzmeister chef des
wahlvorstandes verkündet das ergebnis
langer dank notare
es hat etwas von der verkündung der
lottozahlen und dann kommt er doch kurz
ins schleudern das dass das ergebnis
fehlt nicht meine wirkliche favoriten
gab es nicht nur olaf scholz lächelt ja
lacht für seine verhältnisse besonders
viel siegesgewiss auf saskia esken und
norbert walter borjans entfielen 44 1967
stimmen das entspricht einem anteil von
21,04 prozent auf klara geywitz und olaf
scholz entfielen 48 1473 stimmen das
entspricht einem anteil von 22,68 olaf
scholz hat es fast geschafft der mann
des politischen establishments
finanzminister vizekanzler keiner steht
so für die große koalition wie er
er hat es fürs erste geschafft und denkt
schon an die zukunft das wichtigste ist
dass die spd eine mutige partei ist und
dass sie sich was zutraut und sie soll
sich vor allem zutrauen dass sie wahlen
gewinnen kann das wollen wir gerne
beweisen dass man mit der spd rechnen
muss muss man mit ihnen rechnen
olaf scholz und die brandenburgerin
klara geywitz müssen im november nicht
stichwahl gegen das team das dicht an
ihnen dran ist norbert walter borjans er
hat den wichtigen nrw landesverband
hinter sich und die bundestags
abgeordnete saskia esken
sie sind sich einig dass sie mehr
ausgleich wollen zwischen arm und reich
sie sind sich uneinig mit blick auf die
große koalition
ich gehöre zu denen die die hoffnung nie
aufgeben wir haben noch zeit bis zum
parteitag wir werden sicher auch
informell mal kontakt aufnehmen und
sagen wie kann man denn gemeinsam
weitergehen wir werden versuchen
eine gemeinsame strategie für die
zukunftsfragen zu finden ich sehe da
eine geringe eigentlich keine chance das
heißt also es besteht durchaus auch ein
potenzial natürlich für andere bündnisse
und dann sind da noch die verlierer ralf
stegner zum beispiel linker spd querkopf
aus schleswig holstein und gesine schwan
partei intellektuelle um die frage der
zukunft der großen koalition gehe es in
erster linie nicht mehr für die sich nur
über große oder nichtraucher definiert
dann geht es uns richtig schlecht es
geht darum dass die spd wieder stärker
geht es ja angebot und habe für die
menschen in deutschland
was die richtige politik ist das nicht
abhängig davon wie man das tot von der
bühne im willy brandt haus bis zum büro
des parteivorsitzenden ist es nur eine
frau stuhl fahrt hinauf in den fünften
stock zwei teams kämpfen um den einzug
kämpfen um den schwierigsten job die in
die spd zu vergeben hat einen schönen
guten abend franken
guten abend herr kleber seligen mit
norbert walter borjans nur um
haaresbreite hinter dem vizekanzler und
finanzminister und seinem team sind sie
jetzt die alternative dieses schnell
raus will aus der großen koalition und
die anderen sind ihre gegner in der
frage wir haben diese frage immer so
beantwortet dass wir sagen wir stellen
die inhalte in den vordergrund es geht
jetzt wirklich um wichtige
zukunftsfragen die in deutschland
anstehen die gelöst werden müssen der
klimawandel der digitale wandel und da
müssen verteilungsfragen beantwortet
werden und da stehen wir vor der großen
frage wird es möglich sein mit cdu und
csu
ich glaube nicht daran das heißt sie
tendieren in eine andere richtung als
der vizekanzler und das ist die
alternative die die partei jetzt
entscheiden muss
die partei muss ich vor allem
entscheiden wie sie die zu wie sie in
zukunft ausgerichtet sein möchte werden
mit welcher ausrichtung mit welchen
inhaltlichen angeboten wir auch wieder
größere zustimmung bei den wählern
erhalten wollen und mit welchen wirklich
wichtigen zukunftsfragen wir auch
tatsächlich uns politisch beschäftigen
wollen nun verspricht soziale
gerechtigkeit gute digitalisierung
arbeitsplätze und eine blendende zukunft
auch das team von herrn scholz was ist
das was sie einzigartig und vorzuziehen
macht ich bin einfach der meinung dass
wir mit den kleinen schritten die in der
großen koalition in den letzten sechs
jahren gemacht wurden die großen fragen
nicht beantworten können große koalition
waren in der vergangenheit erstens die
ausnahme und zweitens immer verbunden
die sehr große fragen die dann gelöst
gelöst werden mussten mitglieder auch
wirklich großen dürfen und es sehe ich
heute nicht mehr
und die wären notwendig weil wir
wirklich vor schwierigen aufgaben stehen
das heißt sie sehen die zukunft nicht
mehr an der seite der cdu sondern in
einer zum beispiel rot rot grünen linken
mehrheit ich kann mir in so ner in so
einem bündnis tatsächlich vorstellen
dass wir diese aufgaben besser lösen
können ja aber rein rechnerisch kriegen
sie das nie und nimmer zusammen im
moment
das hat auch damit zu tun dass die spd
im moment wenig zuspruch hat dass die
menschen in der in der spd die die
sozialdemokratische idee nicht mehr
verwirklicht sehen
die idee dass das aufstiegs durch
bildung die idee der der sozialen
gerechtigkeit des ausgleichs auch eines
arbeitsmarkt verordnung herrscht und wo
rechte für arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer herrschen
und da müssen wir einfach wieder einen
anderen ansatz wählen um die
sozialdemokratie wieder in die herzen
auch der menschen zu tragen ihr
wahlkampf innerhalb der partei geht
jetzt in runde zwei die entscheidungs
die ko-runde ist jetzt auch ein bisschen
schluss mit dem kuschelkurs der vorrunde
ich glaube nicht ich glaube dass wir ihm
inhaltlich uns noch stärker abgrenzen
werden das wird auch olaf schulze das
wird auch klara geywitz so sehen aber
dass wir persönlich weiterhin mit einem
fairen umgang mit einem anständigen
umgang miteinander zu rechnen haben das
haben wir uns bisher so versprochen es
werden wir auch weiter so halten und die
entscheidung es am achten dezember beim
parteitag fallen weiter mit kroko oder
schluss da fällt die entscheidung über
die groko das werden unsere unsere
mitglieder unsere delegierten zu
entscheiden haben das ist richtig dort
fallen aber auch viele andere
entscheidungen das sind ja große leiter
leitern 3 geben vorbereitet zum beispiel
zur organisationspolitischen ausstellung
der spd wie sollen neue strukturen
geschaffen werden die auch sagen wir mal
eine online beteiligung ermöglichen und
viele andere dinge
wir werden uns wieder sprechen danke für
heute abend vielen dank
das gespräch hatten wir genauso um 20
uhr 15
heiko maas außenminister war heute ein
paar stunden in der region über die
verteidigungsministerin kramp
karrenbauer für seinen maßgeschneiderte
zu viel und zu unabgestimmt redet ankara
hauptstadt der türkei ein ertrag der
mars reise war von vornherein fest
gebucht der außenminister zeigt präsenz
wo es darauf ankommt ob dann noch mehr
rauskam glück wartet
ruhe bewahren nach vorne blicken die
annäherung suchen an einem schwierigen
partner maß machte beim amtskollegen
cavusoglu deutlich dass substanzielle
differenzen bestehen nicht nur in der
syrien frage aber er sprach auch das
unvermeidliche aus die türkei bleibt ein
wichtiger nato-partner und in syrien
wurden die karten jetzt ganz neu
gemischt ohne europa jetzt gehe es um
humanitäre hilfe
die suche nach einer politischen lösung
um den schutz der bevölkerung ist es für
uns von überragender bedeutung dass wir
zuallererst die sicherstelle dass die
waffenruhe hält und auch verlängert wird
die türkei sieht sich bei ihrem
einmarsch in syrien im recht und von
europa und deutschland im stich gelassen
die frage nach kriegsverbrechen der
verbündeten milizen umgeht schuh
die türkische armee gehe um sichtigvor
sagt er das gelte auch für die
rückführung von flüchtlingen
wir werden auch künftig sicherstellen
dass flüchtlinge nur freiwillig und
unter sicheren bedingungen nach syrien
zurückkehren
wir erwarten aber auch die hilfe der
internationalen gemeinschaft vor allem
deutschlands und der eu und der
vorschlag der deutschen
verteidigungsministerin für eine
internationale schutzzone wenig
realistisch mein cavusoglu maß greift
die steilvorlage auf um im fernen ankara
der kabinettskollegin eine retourkutsche
zu verpassen
die wichtig sind für die menschen in
syrien jetzt eine wortwahl die in berlin
beim koalitionspartner die fieberkurve
steigen lässt wirtschaftsminister
altmaier twittert seit jahrzehnten ist
für jeden politiker klar dass man vom
ausland aus weder politiker der
opposition noch der eigenen regierung
kritisiert ein sichtlich amüsiert
cavusoglu kommentiert das durcheinander
so da müsse sich die deutsche seite wohl
erst einmal sortieren
aber das sei ja das schöne an der
demokratie dass man zumal in koalitionen
unterschiedlicher meinung sein könne
in ankara jedenfalls so darf man
minister schule verstehen werden die
dinge an
das geregelt und wir bleiben in den
nachrichten in der region
russland hat den usa massiven öl
diebstahl vorgeworfen
dabei geht es um die pläne us-soldaten
an ostsyrischen ölquellen zu
stationieren
das sei international des staatliches
banditentum hieß es aus moskau denn das
öl werde gefördert abgefüllt und außer
landes gebracht die usa hatten ihre
pläne damit begründet man wolle die
quellen vor dem sogenannten islamischen
staates schützen
drei wochen lang haben katholische
bischöfe im vatikan beraten über
reformen im amazonasgebiet nun haben sie
ihre forderungen in einem
abschlussdokument vorgestellt so sollen
in ausnahmefällen auch verheiratete
diakone priester werden können
außerdem soll eine kommission die frage
diskutieren ob und unter welchen
umständen frauen zu diakonen geweiht
werden können
was aus den forderungen wird entscheidet
der papst
seit einer woche geht die menschen in
chile auf die straße gestern waren es
mehr als eine million
sie wehren sich gegen hohe preise und
extreme unterschiede zwischen arm und
reich
nun zieht präsident pinera weitere
konsequenzen
er werde ein neues kabinett aufstellen
um den forderungen zu begegnen
entzündet hatten sich die proteste vor
einer woche an höheren ticketpreisen für
die u bahn in barcelona gab es am abend
heftige zusammenstöße zwischen
demonstranten und sicherheitskräften
die polizisten hatten versucht eine
wütende menge vor ihrem hauptquartier
auseinanderzutreiben
insgesamt protestierten rund 350.000
anhänger der unabhängigkeitsbewegung
gegen die verurteilung von neuen
separatistenführer das oberste spanische
gericht hatte vor zwölf tagen hohe
haftstrafen gegen sie verhängt
bei protesten im irak starben gestern
mehr als 40 menschen und auch heute gab
es wieder drei tote außerdem wurden
mindestens 84 menschen verletzt vor
allem in bagdad insgesamt gingen in
mehreren städten tausende auf die straße
gegen die regierung korruption und
misswirtschaft sicherheitskräfte setzten
nicht nur tränengas ein sondern auch
scharfe munition
wir haben das letzte oktoberwochenende
und das heißt heute nacht beginnt die
winterzeit und das wohl nicht zum
letzten mal denn die eu staaten können
sich in sachen zeitumstellung nicht
einigen und weil sie einen
flickenteppich aus zeitzonen vermeiden
wollen bleibt erstmal alles beim alten
morgen früh um 3 uhr wird also der
zeiger um eine stunde zurückgestellt auf
2 uhr und das heißt eine stunde länger
schlafen ohne oh ja und dann haben wir
noch gibt otto 2 12 11 17 37 44
superzahl 6 die angaben sind ohne gewähr
weitere gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto zdf de und im zdf text auf seite
55 6 der herbst macht langsam ernst aber
noch nicht überall zumindest noch nicht
morgen denn im süden gibt es noch einmal
viel sonne bei milden
10 bis 22 grad die mitte dagegen bekommt
viele wolken mit regen ab im norden
scheint bei nur wenigen schauern auch
mal die sonne dort 12 bis 17 grad
danach kühlt es auch im süden deutlich
ab am mittwoch werden nur noch vier bis
elf grad erreicht dabei wird es aber
auch sonnig und trocken
nun empfehlen wir sven voss und das
aktuelle sportstudio morgen abend sind
wir hier mit den ergebnissen der
thüringen ball
[Musik]